[Música]
y como lo venimos hablando en la
economía junto a danielle hablando vamos
a hablar por supuesto de lo que pasa en
nuestro continente en términos
económicos nosotros tenemos hoy como
invitado a marcelo montenegro el ex
ministro de economía y finanzas públicas
de bolivia ministro gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de martes en directo américa de
france 24 en estudio también conmigo
está nuestra periodista de económica ni
el hablando la ministro muy buenos días
y comienzo pues por preguntarle cuál es
esa fórmula entonces para que
bolivia sea tan resiliente a todo esto
que está pasando en el mundo la guerra
en ucrania la crisis de contenedores
todo que es afectando los precios en la
región como hace bolivia para que no le
afecte tanto
buenos dias daniela un saludo de américa
de france 24 en todo el mundo
las fórmulas que nos está aplicamos es
simplemente
fomenta la producción en el área
agropecuaria y
aplicar un esquema de subvenciones en el
área productiva con una empresa que
hemos creado el 2008 nuestra primera
nuestro primer ciclo de gobierno y esta
empresa lo que hace es fomentar la
producción
subvencionando obviamente los insumos
pero también subvencionando la
producción de alimentos claves como el
maíz el trigo
el sordo entonces esto es un elemento
importante porque también permite que
los alimentos lleguen a un precio
moderado a los meses de los bolivianos
es un elemento que hay que será luego
también se hace una subvención a los
energéticos al 10 y en la gasolina que
si imagínate que si estuviera esto
emparejado a lo que está sucediendo
ahora en el mundo generaría obviamente
un traspaso inmediato de los precios de
los primeros artículos de la canasta
familiar entonces no nos aplicamos este
esquema de subvenciones y lo hacemos
recientemente lo hacemos desde el 2008
de manera tal que evitamos estos shocks
que ahora en todo el mundo es un
problema
claro ministro también le quiero
preguntar entiendo que esto se logra con
subsidios que el gobierno le da pues de
temas de combustibles temas de alimentos
está diciendo que ustedes lo implementan
en el país desde el año 2008 pero
digamos que esto no podría tener una
consecuencia negativa digamos aún más a
largo plazo a la economía boliviana
luego de tantos subsidios como ustedes
hacen para que esto digamos no ocurra no
se convierte en una burbuja que luego
estalle
hay que señalar obviamente todos los
recursos son infinitos en algún momento
hay que hacer un cambio en el tema de la
importación de diesel y gasolina y eso
es lo que estamos aplicando en este
momento un programa de sustitución de
importaciones con plantas de biodiesel
que van a entrar en funcionamiento ya el
próximo año una planta pequeña y el 2023
o perdón 2024 una planta
más grande que nos va a permitir en
conjunto sustituirla entre un 43 a 45
por ciento de las importaciones de
diesel y gasolina también vamos
aplicando la mezcla no de etanol en
nuestra gasolina de tal manera que
también es un ahorro importante bolivia
tiene
una industria
cañera importante entonces lo que
hacemos ahora es comprarles a los
cañeros etanol y mezclando con la
gasolina esta sustitución de impotencia
nos va a permitir ahorrar en ese en ese
n sea en esa área también tenemos una
importación importante de agroquímicos y
también ahí nosotros estamos con nuestra
planta de urea vamos a poner una segunda
planta de urea y también ahí vamos a
generar producción pero también ahorro
de divisas de tal manera que
estamos emparejando el aumento del
consumo en estas áreas agrícola y
también en el área del transporte para
que para luego tener hay un ahorro que
nos permite tener hacer sostenible estas
subvenciones
ministro con respecto a justamente a eso
de hacer sostenibles las subvenciones lo
que se ha dicho también es que bolivia
ha venido acumulando una
pues que se han venido desacelerando las
reservas internacionales y en algún
momento como lo decíamos pues
posiblemente se van a quedar muy cortos
de reservas internacionales como van a
ser para acumular más reservas y no
dejar que se les vacíe digamos esa esa
canasta de dólares
bueno en este momento nuestro nivel de
reservas
tiene en las métricas internacionales
para más d
4 o 5 meses de importación primera cosa
hay que tomar eso en cuenta
segundo que nuestra producción de litio
ya inicia él
en nuestras piscinas de carbonato de
litio ya empiezan una producción fuerte
del 2023 y de seguro que también nuestra
extracción directa de hidróxido de litio
también van a tener va a generar un
un incremento en el aumento de las
exportaciones
dado que el precio de la tonelada de
litio ha pasado de 5000 a en un momento
a 75 mil euros 170 mil dólares tenemos
ahí una importante fuente de recursos
nuestras plantas separadoras de zinc que
ahí adentro del zinc tenemos minerales
más valiosos en 90 veces de lo que vale
el zinc también maneja en producción el
2024 entonces ahí vamos a ir obteniendo
recursos externos de tal manera que
nuestras reservas no van a tener
según digamos la previsión que tú
señalas a una inclusión no de ninguna
manera sino que en todo caso tenemos
esas fuentes de mediano y largo paso y
en el corto plazo no tenemos acceso al
crédito externo no las multilaterales
como big and banco mundial café w
café rica por todas ellas tenemos
márgenes para
endeudarnos y llegar a hacer estos
proyectos que nos van a permitir generar
estos recursos externos claro ministro
montenegro yo yo le quería preguntar una
cosa con toda esta transición que
ustedes se tienen planteada de no
subsidiar tanto los combustibles
entiendo que para 2024 si no estoy mal
que dijo la fecha temen ustedes una
subida en el precio de los combustibles
o tienen planeado después mantenerla
como está ahora
está planificado tenerla como nos
venimos llevando desde hace años porque
ni bien nos habíamos enterado del
fenómeno de lo político y de riesgo
entre rusia y ucrania nosotros hemos
internalizado dentro del programa fiscal
financiero así lo llamamos que firma el
ministerio de economía con el banco
central y final nos digamos
estresados de importación de diésel
gasolina
subvencionada
alimentos entonces eso ya lo hemos
internalizado y ya hemos presupuestado
para la gestión y esperemos que este
elemento se vayan moderando y iii y eso
nos va a permitir por en esta gestión
mitigar esos escenarios o ese ambiente
digamos de volatilidad e incertidumbre
que hay en el mundo en este momento
claro ministro el presidente pues ha
destacado en varias oportunidades la
forma poco ortodoxa del gobierno
boliviano de manejar las finanzas que
destacaría usted o qué recomendación les
daría a los otros gobiernos que tienen
una manera más ortodoxa de manejar la
economía que de pronto están viendo
altos índices de inflación o recesión
inclusive fantasma de la recesión
rondando por la región cuál es esa
recomendación mejor dicho si si el
modelo que ustedes tienen en bolivia es
aplicable para otros países entendiendo
obviamente las políticas internas y pues
en cada país por separado
yo no quisiera
la idea de que no nos damos una
recomendación simplemente lo que podemos
nosotros demostrar nuestra experiencia
como país y decir que nosotros hemos
primero pasado de un esquema dolarizado
que tenía el sistema financiero a un
esquema bolivian izado es lo que le ha
permitido a la política monetaria y
fiscal tener grados de libertad para
poder actuar en los momentos críticos
cómo aplicar estas políticas de
estabilización después de estar saliendo
de un escenario igual depresivo cuando
bolivia ha sufrido una caída de más del
9% en la actividad real del producto
interno bruto y que en términos para el
tamaño de nuestra economía ha
significado más de 4 mil millones de
dólares y una pérdida de empleo de más
de quinientas mil fuentes laborales
creemos que la bolivianización
apuesta por la redistribución del
ingreso mitigar desigualdades es
fundamental para que circule como en la
anatomía humana toda la sangre por todo
el cuerpo y no se acumula en un solo
lugar esos son los elementos que yo
destacó como los elementos virtuosos del
modelo aplicado en bolivia